let me understand something you were
very careful in your career yeah and um
okay in sports illustrated of course you
wore bikinis and stuff like that you
were the only one i think on three
covers or something crazy like that but
uh you were asked by playboy to be uh in
playboy you did not go naked
you appeared on the cover but you were
not nude you also inc in uh national
lampoon's vacation your character was
supposed to be topless you refused right
you stayed in your bra and panties in
that swimming scene is that it so you
have you have never done nudity am i
correct correct like cindy crawford was
in here and she had done nudity like she
did like you know tasteful nudes yes
that was by design though you did not
want to show off your assets that way
not even consideration magazines nothing
like that
i mean i did i did um i was
nude on the set but with nothing showing
kind of things right do you regret that
because when you're in the prime
modeling years you would have had that
those pictures forever like you know
sort of frozen into the thing and so
would my kids and
you know i was i always my number one
thing in life
i knew i wanted to be a mom i
the idea of a big happy family you know
and and that was my goal and i thought
you know do i want the kids to have to
be there on the playground with kids
going here's your mom
you have none of those issues with the
kids because you you don't have those
pictures floating around yeah
and and you never got into any scandal
with sex videos or anything like that
you avoided all that [ __ ] not yet not
yet but